oh yeah donnie's one of the last of the
few guys that's like action star doing
his own stuff it's like there's no more
stephen's the goal he's got he left that
face hiding his face hiding his face
watching that back is not as bad as i
remember no
this episode is sponsored by storyblocks
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntman react i'm joined
here by guillaume travis if you guys
have not watched an episode before he's
been on a bunch of episodes he's done a
bunch of crazy things he's a wonderful
host and travis here helped teach me how
to do a high fall without killing myself
it's pretty amazing it's like you have
two of your teachers here yeah i worked
on your falls not jumping off a high
thing yep and he taught your falls
jumping off of high things uh a little
cool thing for y'all to know is that
this dude is the reason why i moved to
los angeles he made it so that way i
felt really comfortable and fell in love
with the whole idea of becoming a stunt
man so yo fans of black panther fans of
corridor digital you're welcome i made
this live
i would like my ten percent guys
[Laughter]
so we're gonna be looking at a lot of
cool clips today some crazy classic
scenes i got a janky fight scene with
steven seagal oh anything with stevenson
law he gets his butt kicked in it what
spoilers all right let's jump in
oh oh that was a okay that was kind of
quick i guess yeah
all right you know oh man
you sent them like 15 feet with that
punch so i'm gonna just say this i think
tyson's fighting actually looks pretty
good they're smart they just use his
punching you know like cater to your
strengths for sure
oh eat that
[Laughter]
oh
that was dirty yeah i don't like those
falls no i'm not a fan of those
right in the pudge
i would like to say that we don't even
know if that was him that was a tight
shot right right yeah was that him it
was definitely could have been an arm
double he's like i'm not letting mike
tyson punch you so what i'm saying bro
dude look at the kick the kick
feels like a little tiny kick too wait
and then jump the line on the kick
totally yeah give me a frame by frame
it's on this side of the line
why would you do that you don't live on
the other side afterwards no we're just
gonna go back to where we were just like
one of those times when you're like they
didn't copy my previous i feel like they
didn't even shoot the previous i think
they show up on the day we're like let's
choreograph some stuff dude the amount
of inserts to hide the stun doubles is
insane on this one so many they hide the
stun double for like every time like he
gets hit yeah like anything that would
be like steven seagal wouldn't want to
do it's like there's no more steven's
the goal he's got he left that face
hiding his face hiding his face like the
only thing in the bar i can see steven
just being like oh oh i'm out yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no no no no no
you know i haven't seen a single wide
shot with both of them in it at the same
time i don't think steven seagal and
mike tyson were ever on set at the same
time you gotta hear the ending one-liner
[Music]
can you drink piss
okay mike
i'm not talking [ __ ] about my
smoke yo
mike you looked great in this yeah mike
you killed it a legend sir you're a
legend
you can be a king
so i brought this because i really enjoy
gareth evans ability to capture the
carnage of action and so i was very
interested to see like what would he do
if he doesn't have all the really dope
indonesian martial artists like how
would his action look and he came out
with this show called gangs of london
and this is like the first fight scene
you see and i was like okay it's him
he's the sauce
[Music]
oh yeah eat that you know surprising the
cam is a little shakier than i expected
right but it's not disorienting because
they're not chopping a whole bunch it's
got a very rackaracka feel too yeah
totally
oh yeah that guy's gonna need to see a
doctor yes i wonder if that guy had a
pad on or if that guy had a fake leg
thing with fake leg cause that's a weird
bend the other thing i can think of is
these twisted so his leg does this but
they hold the shoe yeah the opposite
direction opposite yeah
hits that actually look painful right he
finds a way to make you feel everything
and you see the whole stunt which is
cool the thing that stands about this
choreography and it's something that i
like to do myself is that it's all about
moments right you forget all about all
the other stuff in the middle right like
i ask people all the time what's your
favorite fight scene show me 15 moves of
choreo from it no one can but like
what's your favorite moment and most
people can remember a moment so that's
what it's all about
[Music]
that was gnarly right
that was straight rage status right
there this is rad this is like just
sturdy enough to feel real but it's just
clean enough that you can see every
single
decision there's like just enough
suspended reality too where i'm like
could this guy really take out this many
guys but then the way he's doing it i'm
like maybe yeah he's not like destroying
them he's just luckily getting those
points off and he didn't do this
no
none of that no swimming
[Music]
so go check that out i'm you know i was
happy to bring that it was good it was
dope it was legit you know looking at
some really amazing stunts i wanted to
hit you guys with a clip that maybe you
haven't seen oh this is robin hood
[Music]
oh and then yeah
wait wait wait wait go back go back go
back hold up replay that way replay that
one falls on the halberds
[Laughter]
right into the spear you could have
picked a better spot to fall
[Music]
whoa that was pretty gangster that's
sick yo handless parkour actually if you
look closely you can see his hands
aren't tied for the horse shot whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa nico no need to ruin your
photography right sorry
guys
to rename this episode to rooting the
magic dude you know what's crazy all
things considered is like this scene is
so difficult to pull off even nowadays
with horses and not many extras and
background elements i can't even imagine
how they pulled this off back in the day
like this would be a nightmare if you
asked me to coordinate this in 2021 i
feel like there's an element of just
like roll the dice see what happens
[Music]
wait what
whoa
at first i was like are they gonna play
this in reverse right how did they
achieve that back in the days wait hold
up they really had to use that i think
they really used the pulley system you
see the rope gets sucked in at the end
too so if he doesn't get off of it he's
gonna get into it get off get off get up
it's really a little hard getting
background info on these movies from you
know before world war ii this is so
impressive to me that my man was able to
hold on to this climb it up to the top
right not let go wow and he's not
strapped to the rope not at all nope i
give him a lot of props too man this is
like a long shot that they carry no cuts
or anything you know what i'm saying
like even in modern day we would have
probably triple cut that if you were to
execute this scene in 2021 with a lead
actor like that we're having safety
lines on him we may be able to do it
with a horse and pull him off but if
it's that wide we're not doing with the
outgoing we're not doing it yeah that's
crazy man highly impressive hey while
those boys are busy reacting downstairs
we're up here crunching the numbers you
ever wonder what old dune shields look
like in the new dune movie well you're
gonna find out soon i've been working
hard matt's having a mental breakdown
and it's all coming together and
dropping tomorrow check it out
raging fire i've heard so many good
things about this movie this is like
donnie and doing heat
first off you if you wrap a bulletproof
vest around your eyes is that what's on
his
i was like just pissed a whipping
everybody because is he really moving
this fast still or is this some health
it's help it's definitely something he
still gives it though man how old is
donnie in do you guys know dude he's
like 50 something old enough that i'm
curious if that's him or if that's help
in post because that was fast
now everybody gets real punches
you get one here you go you get one
there you go it's like the one thing
i've never got to do in my career is be
in god mode right i'm pretty jealous of
this like i would love to do a scene
where i'm literally just taking out a
hundred dudes just serving hands yeah
guess what everybody these hands are
rated e for everyone
[Laughter]
what's the donnie in sauce what's the
dani and magic why is danian a name that
we know i think john yen is just one of
those names that never actually fully
made it mainstream in america never got
that chance like jackie or jet li right
so for anyone that's a follower of you
know cinema and action films overseas
this guy is a legend just like you know
samo kind of broke over when he had you
know martial law and stuff here in
america right donnie's never really had
that chance yet so in my personal
opinion that's why he's so famous he's
like the lone ranger i think his biggest
draw to the states was it man but he had
like opportunities like jackie pulled
him in for shanghai nights yeah that's
right in my opinion donnie's one of the
last of the few guys that's like i
should start doing his own stuff
obviously we got guys like scott atkins
you guys have had on the couch they're
doing his thing as an action star but i
really think it's like the last of a
dying breed yeah i'm sorry i'm really
hoping that we get a new generation soon
so now it's time for like new guys to
come up and we'll see what happens like
with andy long and andy lay and you know
maybe de silva who's gonna say it
there's just not many guys that can act
and actually do actions you know i'm
giving you ad-libs while i'm getting my
headphones
giving my emmy daddy
[Music]
dude when it flies in your meth lab am i
right
so that's how nico affords all this
stuff
can if you guys break down this fall for
me dude i know exactly which one i'm
talking about yeah this one's been
actually asked for a bunch of comments
on this channel and so hey if you have
more stunts you want to see us break
down please leave a comment this is
exactly from the comments here we go
[Applause]
all right watching that back it's not as
bad as i remember no when i first
watched the show as a fan of the show i
remember being like who in the hell did
that right watching this back now i
would do that yeah it's kind of like a
little homage to dragons forever yeah
yeah totally yeah those guys are really
hitting those things oh yeah so
basically what he did is he's starting
on this platform right here and what
you're gonna do is execute what's known
as like a clip fall which basically you
clip and then you redirect your energy
the reason why i remember being more
brutal was that i thought he went
straight to his back what he does here
is a technique called a toe tap so he's
gonna scrub off his speed after he hits
here as he's going down instead of
hitting his back first which would have
been brutal he hits his feet toe tap
then collapses his legs and then goes to
his butt and then to his back we spoke
about this before haven't you yeah
i will say this though to give full
respect to the stuntman that did it
because we're not trying to say it's so
easy anyone could do this no even though
you know that's exactly what you're
gonna do when you're standing up on a
platform and you've got a hundred people
in the casting crew looking at you and
you're about to jump you definitely have
a sort of fear running through your
brain as well as like a ton of variables
that could happen right like he could
hit that thing and let's say he hits it
so far he just pings off right away and
goes straight to his back that's a
problem you know he hits his head
against the little pole that's there
yeah you know something along the set
it's a small gap that he has to also hit
as well right so it takes precision it
takes practice probably did what do you
think what do you think the average
amount takes he would have done this so
here's the thing if he fell straight to
his back i think they were only done
like once or twice with this controlled
he may have done it maybe three times
yeah maybe five on a high end if they
really needed it and i only say that
because there's a camera move tied into
it so sometimes when you have moves like
that you do another one just because
camera framing is just slightly off you
know what i'm saying but yeah that is
definitely a gnarly one you know gee i
did do a fall in our dnd series yeah i
applied all my training from youtube no
hey that was good oh yeah it was onto a
pad you know real hard stuff
real stunt man here yeah let's see this
a bolt the size of a baseball bat flies
straight past your head
so take a look at son of a dungeon which
is our dungeons and dragons series it's
got a bunch of crazy animation green
screen stuff an incredible game board
that dwarven forge helped us put
together anyways you can check it out
quarterdigital.com this is a free
episode on this channel if you want to
check it out but just as you go through
the doorway he swings
what kind of pad did you fall on is our
like port-a-pit or whatever it is okay
okay does it run and then
spin around and you know try to get back
his face off well yeah because i didn't
want to lie with a flat back yeah i
didn't want to miss the pad because i
couldn't look at it
so yeah line it up and jump backwards
did the whole chin tuck arms out
look at that look at that and the legs
too irregular i like it
the same you did a regular brush
you guys taught me very well thank you
you got the hair flip bro which i can't
do so yeah that's that's how jackie
can't teach that
yeah yo thanks for having me guys be
sure to hit that like button comment and
subscribe for brand new episodes
so blessed to be here on the quarter
couch can't wait to see what you guys
have in store for the rest of us
oh man all right a little lesser known
fact about this show on react right here
one of the sponsors that we have is
today's sponsor storyblocks and we've
been using them here at corridor for
years why because it allows us to tell
stories stories like the time when i was
driving across nebraska and i picked up
that group of vagabonds as we were
driving across nebraska i told the guys
guys look there's one place where
creators and businesses get their stock
assets and that's story blocks and they
were like yes jake thank you for
bringing this up because i've been
waiting to tell you about the time that
i became a wizard and when i became a
wizard i had to travel to the deep delta
to save a young girl held hostage by an
evil man the thing about telling a story
is that you need images audio assets
motion graphics after effects templates
and more to pair with your story it
can't just be words high quality 4k
b-roll from a virtually unlimited
library of assets to select from that is
what you're going to need and that's
exactly what storyblocks has to offer so
anyways the rest of this young girl well
then guess what she becomes a boxer a
world-class champion prize fighting
boxer who's all the way to the top she
went to her pr manager and said hey do
we have story box they have a
subscription plan for anybody for all
different levels of pricing and with an
unlimited all-access plan this prize
fighter and her team could download as
much b-roll and stock assets as they
needed and use them in whatever they
wanted however they wanted because they
were all royalty-free so anyways she
becomes a prize fighter what does she do
okay she marries a prize fighting boxer
they have a bunch of beautiful prized
fighting babies that's what they did all
because of story blocks so if you're
serious about being a professional
creator this is one of the tools you're
gonna need it's not the tool you're
gonna need to make your whole process
more efficient more effective more
creative and more fun so if you guys are
interested head on over to
storyblocks.comcrew to get started
that's storybox.com corridor crew get
signed up today it's a tool we use here
every day seriously this isn't just me
making up stories
we literally
chase is using it right now
told you
it's an absolute honor to be on the
couch with you too gee i haven't seen
you in a long time man oh yeah where can
people follow you if they want to follow
you what are you up to so i changed my
name on instagram guys it's now ghee the
silva green check me out on there keep
up with all the cool things that's been
going on and travis you not only do you
have an instagram which you should shout
out in a second but you also have a gym
that offers classes and things like that
tell us a little bit about 100 man so if
you guys want to stay up to date with my
personal journey my instagram is the
travis wong and i also co in a gym like
niko talked about alongside aaron tony
who's been on the couch before so if you
want to take classes in stunts parkour
tricking or private lessons or go to
open gyms hit us up at joining all
movement we're on youtube and you can
find us on instagram at j.a man you guys
sound like you've been on a video or two
before you guys are so smooth with your
outros
i've been waiting two years for this
rehearsing in my bedroom
thanks for watching everybody we'll see
the next one